[Musique]
politique bonsoir et bienvenue dans les
deux politiques votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation en association avec TV 78
épisode de 229 mon invité ce soir et la
députée LFI de Seine-et-Marne RCA
[Musique]
merci bonsoir vous êtes l'un des
nouveaux visages de l'Assemblée
nationale vous faites partie donc du
groupe de la France insoumise élue dans
la septième circonscription de
Seine-et-Marne vous étiez auparavant
professeur de français et vous faites
partie de la commission des affaires
étrangères aujourd'hui c'est le début de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar le coup
d'envoi était donné à 17h alors cette
semaine en commission des affaires
étrangères une table ronde a été
organisée sur les conditions de
préparation de cette compétition au
cours de cette table ronde la Commission
a interrogé maxunnen le chef du bureau
de l'OIT à Doha un bureau qui existe
depuis 2017 alors qu'elle a été son son
point de vue sur les conditions de
travail au Qatar que sait-on de ces
conditions alors il a il s'est voulu
rassurant en tout cas c'est comme ça que
je l'ai ressenti
qu'il a selon lui il y a des
améliorations qui sont mises en place
pour autant de mon point de vue c'est
reste nettement insuffisant
et puis le seul point qui qui m'inquiète
d'ailleurs parce que au-delà des
conditions de travail enfin on remarque
aussi voilà un véritable problème
environnemental
j'ai du mal à comprendre aussi pourquoi
on met autant d'argent dans une coupe du
monde enfin c'est beaucoup plus
pharaonique par rapport à d'habitude
et puis je suis très inquiète pour la
protection des données des personnes qui
vont se rendre là-bas la CNIL a
récemment donné un avis
disant aux gens de faire attention
elle conseille aux gens de prendre voilà
des soit des fins d'effacer toute leur
donner sur leur smartphone avant de
l'emmener ou bien d'en prendre un tout
neuf parce qu'il y a un risque de se
faire pirater ses données voilà donc
c'est assez inquiétant au cours de ces
entretiens qu'avez-vous appris sur le
droit du travail au Qatar et sur les
réformes qui ont été engagées depuis
2017 le Qatar met en avant des réformes
sur le droit du travail depuis 2017
alors après je pense qu'effectif je
pense qu'effectivement le
Qatar en taille en time quelques
réformes parce que voilà c'est à chaque
fois qu'il y a un événement comme ça de
7 ampleur
ça a forcément un impact pour pour
comment dire enfin redorer un peu
l'image du pays qui accueille voilà
après moi ce qui enfin comme j'ai dit
malgré tout ça reste très insuffisant et
puis et puis surtout je m'inquiète de la
même de la pérennité des des quelques
améliorations qu'il y a pu y avoir quoi
alors la décision de confier
l'organisation de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar a été décidé par la FIFA ce ne
sont pas les les États qui qui l'ont
décidé mais ils ont ensuite la
possibilité de boycotter ou non
l'événement alors dans une tribune que
vous avez cossigné avec notamment Alexis
Corbière qui porte ce sujet dans le
journal donc du dimanche le 23 septembre
quelles sont les raisons qui vous
amènent à boycotter cet événement
alors oui de effectivement je demande un
boycott diplomatique j'insiste sur
l'idée de bio boycot diplomatique l'idée
c'est pas d'empêcher les gens de
regarder la Coupe du Monde l'idée c'est
vraiment que l'État se positionne
clairement en faveur des droits humains
voilà c'est le fait de boycoter
diplomatiquement le voilà de pas
apporter d'aide particulière à la Coupe
du monde à la Coupe du Monde de Qatar le
fait de ne pas se déplacer là-bas enfin
c'est ce serait un signe fort pour
montrer le fait que on est en désaccord
avec le manque de respect des droits
humains et alors vraiment aussi je veux
insister sur quelque chose c'est que
quand je parle du manque de respect des
droits humains au Qatar pour moi c'est
pas un problème civilisationnel parce
que certains veulent nous faire croire
ça en pensant que voilà on a les bons
occidentaux d'un côté et on a le monde
arabe de l'autre qui ne respecte pas les
droits humains moi je pense que le
problème fondamental c'est le
capitalisme qui est là enfin porter à
son paroxysme Emmanuel Macron a répondu
à Alexis Corbière il a appelé à ne pas
politiser le sport parce que vous lui
répondez
le sport mais en réalité le sport c'est
politique et d'ailleurs les lavant bien
souvent les les comment dire les les
politiques les freins les présidentes ne
se gênent pas pour si je n'ai pas pour
le faire donc je pense que c'est un faux
procès alors malgré toutes ces
controverses la Coupe du Monde attire
tout de même des milliers de Français au
Qatar ils seront 10000 à y aller contre
27000 il y a 4 ans en Russie ils seront
accompagnés de quelques centaines de
gendarmes français donc qui seront
présents pour aider à la sécurité au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez dénoncé cet accord entre le
gouvernement français et le gouvernement
cathari pourquoi
alors encore une fois c'est parce que
voilà je je
pense qu'un ce qui m'a dérangé dans le
cet accord déjà c'était le fait que le
gouvernement français soulignait les
liens d'amitié avec le Qatar et comme je
disais enfin comment est-ce qu'on peut
parler de liens d'amitié avec un pays
qui est aussi peu respectueux des droits
de l'homme aussi peu respectueux de
notre écosystème on va déjà c'était
cette formulation qui me posait
véritablement problème après il y a
autre chose qui me dérange c'est que on
a parlé essentiellement d'y envoyer des
hommes sûrement parce que d'ailleurs
effectivement la condition de la femme
au Qatar et la problématique que et que
même finalement d'ailleurs les les
comment dire le droit du travail n'est
même pas enfin pour ce qui est pour ce
qu'il existe des pas pensé pour les
femmes puisque en fait les femmes ne
travaillent pas spécialement au Qatar
quoi
alors cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez examiné la loi de
programmation et d'orientation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la période
2023 2027 baptisé Love Me elle prévoit
donc 15 milliards de budget en plus pour
le ministère intérieur pour transformer
numériquement le ministère les
procurations électorales seront
désormais des matérialisées les victimes
pourront aussi porter plainte par
visio-conférence est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose de simplifier les procédures
alors j'ai remarqué effectivement comme
hier je l'ai soulign pendant le débat
que le gouvernement avait un véritable
goût pour la simplification en vérité
derrière ce goût pour la simplification
il y a plus il y a une un désir
finalement de démanteler le service
public et mon c'est le cas là en
l'occurrence pour comment dire pour les
voilà les commissariats mais ça c'est ça
se reflète dans ça s'est déjà même
reflété par le passé dans plein d'autres
services publics moi je sais enfin je
sais que par exemple quand on essaye de
joindre les impôts c'est compliqué
donc ce que ce que je crains c'est que
l'idée derrière tout ça ce soit de
supprimer des postes ou de ne pas les ou
de ne pas chercher à recruter d'ailleurs
c'est ce que disait la Défenseur des
droits c'est la Défenseur des droits
c'est ce qu'elle a souligné dans son
rapport elle a dit que
cette dématérialisation aboutissait
généralement à des postes en moins et
moi je pense
je pense notamment aux victimes de
violences sexistes sexuelles et
intrafamiliales qui s'est déjà très déjà
compliqué en soi de porter plainte si en
plus on se retrouve juste derrière un
ordinateur
en plus des fois avec une comment dire
pour certaines personnes ça peut être
compliqué de réussir à comprendre
comment remplir tel ou telle formulaire
parfois on peut avoir des problèmes
aussi même de connexion des fois on
parle dans certains endroits on a tout
simplement des problèmes d'accès à
Internet en tout cas un bon débit donc
enfin je pense que ça rajoute des
obstacles pour des gens qui ont qui au
contraire aurait besoin d'être davantage
accompagné alors sur les moyens des
services publics la majorité vous répond
que ce seront 8500 policiers sur cinq
ans qui seront recrutés les policiers
disposeront aussi de nouveaux outils
numériques des caméras à piétons des
caméras embarquées une vision que LFI et
les écologistes rejettent plus de
policiers ça ne permettra pas de réduire
la délinquance selon
alors déjà c'est que ce que alors ce que
je disais en fait c'est que plus de
policiers ok mais alors le problème
c'est que qu'est-ce qu'on a en fait ces
policiers aussi ça veut dire que si
c'est juste pour en mettre plein pendant
des manifestations si c'est juste pour
enfin juste donner enfin
donner un sentiment de enfin vouloir
rassurer par de la présence mais sans
véritablement leur donner des des
missions qui permettraient réellement
d'améliorer le quotidien des Français
des Français je enfin je ne vois pas
l'intérêt l'autre chose c'est que je
demande à avoir parce que quand j'ai
rencontré les policiers de Villeparisis
ils m'ont clairement dit qu'il y avait
un vrai problème de recrutement donc
enfin de façon générale il y a un
problème de recrutement dans la fonction
publique
il suffit pas simplement de faire des
déclarations d'attention de voilà on va
recruter des gens il faut améliorer les
conditions de travail aussi des des
policiers pour que pour qu'ils aient
pour que les gens aient envie de
de postuler et améliorer les conditions
de travail des policiers c'est notamment
revoir leurs missions c'est à dire que
les voilà les commentaires mobiliser
dans des manifestations
à tel point que ça ça fait augmenter les
tensions je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne idée les surmobile les
surmobilisés sur des questions de lutte
contre le cannabis je pense pas que ce
soit une bonne idée non plus je pense
que à ce niveau ils sont très comment
dire ils sont très sollicités sur cette
question là alors même que nous à la
France insoumise qu'on défend c'est
l'idée de légaliser pour plutôt mettre
les moyens en Allemagne voilà pour nous
mettre les moyens sur une politique
sanitaire publique
pour voilà et pour faire de la
prévention plutôt que de la répression
qui en fait touche essentiellement les
milieux populaires
vous en avez parlé cette semaine vous
vous êtes rendu donc au commissariat de
la police municipale de Villeparisis
pour échanger donc avec les policiers
quels sont les problématiques qui vous
ont remonter alors c'est vrai que
justement une des premières
problématiques qui m'ont remontées
c'était le manque d'effectif et donc du
coup un certain épuisement c'est vrai il
se sentent voilà sur sollicité pour
compenser le manque de personnel alors
eux ce qu'ils pensent être une enfin
voilà ce qui voit comme étant une
manière de se comment dire de soulager
leurs épaules c'est d'avoir d'avoir
beaucoup de vidéosurveillance mais moi
je pense pas que ce soit la bonne
solution je pense que une caméra ne
remplacera jamais un être humain donc je
peux comprendre voilà le fait que
effectivement
eux ce qu'il voit c'est que ils sont
très peu nombreux et que du coup et que
du coup enfin tout aide
technologique pour eux et la bienvenue
mais moi je pense pas que ce soit la
solution je pense qu'il faut remettre de
l'humain qu'il faut qu'il faut plus du
pain davantage de à ce niveau là pour le
coup en matière de police de proximité
il faut davantage de personnel et non
pas des caméras qui sont d'ailleurs
intrusive
et qu'ils vont l'aide d'autant plus que
d'ailleurs parmi les dans la loi
Darmanin
une une des propositions à laquelle je
me suis opposée c'était de faciliter le
comment dire l'accès pour les policiers
aux images des caméras donc
alors même que d'ailleurs la police
municipale de Villeparisis m'avait
présenté le système des réquisitions
comme un garde-fou c'est à dire il me
disait vous inquiétez pas Madame soudés
même si ça peut paraître intrusif on a
quand même un garde-fou c'est enfin tout
le monde ne peut pas accéder comme il
veut aux caméras il faut une réquisition
c'est très encadré on voilà c'est les
images sont détruites régulièrement etc
mais donc je me dis que si on comment
dire si on casse les garde-fous encore
une fois dans l'idée de simplifier
soi-disant
ça m'inquiète beaucoup alors depuis
votre élection donc vous êtes engagé
très fortement pour soutenir Sala à
mourir un avocat franco-palestinien
emprisonné en Israël alors que lui
est-il reproché alors oui c'est un alors
il subit une certaine forme de
harcèlement depuis 20 ans maintenant
donc c'est il a été régulièrement
placé en détention là encore récemment
donc le depuis le 7 mars 2022 et en fait
tous les trois mois le tribunal
militaire israélien est censé statuer
pour savoir si ça a des tensions se
poursuit ou aussi les libérer et si il
est libéré s'il peut rester en Israël là
où il est né en fait
parce qu'il est Franco il est Franco
palestinien en fait c'est
des Palestiniens mais en plus là en
l'occurrence il s'agit d'un de nos
compatriotes et donc en fait on lui on
sait pas vraiment ce qu'on lui reproche
dans la mesure où il est détenu sans
charge ni procès c'est ça qui est aussi
extrêmement dérangeant et d'ailleurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
ministre des Affaires étrangères madame
Colonna
c'est exprimé
enfin lors d'une commission lors de la
commission des affaires étrangères
elle s'est exprimée à ce sujet en disant
que
pour elle il était effectivement
important que ça allait à Maurice soit
libéré et qu'il puisse vivre là où il le
souhaite entouré sa famille parce que
par ailleurs sa femme est interdite
interdite de visite sur le soldier sur
le sol israélien depuis un moment
maintenant donc il peut pas voir sa
femme il ne peut pas voir ses enfants et
tout ça pour finalement une ils ont
assez obscure quoi
[Musique]
et moi ce que voilà ce que je regrette
c'est le manque enfin le le manque
d'action de la France ça veut dire que
là la France agit mais n'ose pas hausser
le ton
sous prétexte que si à l'os le ton
Israël risque de se braquer je dis
prochain ce sera le jour de la niche
parlementaire de la France insoumise
c'est un jour consacré aux examens des
propositions de loi d'un groupe
politique à l'Assemblée nationale
d'opposition alors à l'ordre du jour il
y aura 12 textes tous ne pourront pas
être examinés bien sûr en une journée le
premier texte sera une proposition de
résolution qui concernera la demande de
création d'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire donc qui fait suite aux
informations relatives aux hubert-files
publié donc cet été en souhaitant
identifier les actions du lobbying uber
pour pouvoir s'implanter en France et
sur leur conséquences sociales
économique et environnementales alors
cette commission donc d'enquête
parlementaire vise Emmanuel Macron que
permettrait-elle
alors l'idée c'est de poursuivre un
combat qui dure depuis un moment mais
disons de mettre en vraiment en lumière
des choses qu'on sait déjà se dire que
c'est juste que ça permet d'avoir
vraiment des preuves parce qu'il y a un
véritable problème de lobbying de façon
générale mais notamment avec cette
plateforme uber qui a quand même comme
particularité effectivement de détruire
les conditions de travail c'est à dire
que comme je le disais encore tout
récemment avec un taxi c'est Hubert
c'est vraiment de c'est l'escla enfin
c'est l'esclavage des temps modernes
quoi et
donc des personnes justement qui à la
base vivaient de leur travail avec les
taxis se retrouve menacés
par ce genre de plateforme et ce que je
trouvais ce qui est scandaleux c'est que
cette destruction des conditions de
travail cette esclavage est temps
moderne a été soutenue par le pouvoir en
place et donc le c'est tout cette
commission d'enquête permettrait de
mettre en lumière et là on voit qu'il y
a vraiment un souci c'est que justement
quand Daniel Simonet a souhaité
présenter cette de résolution en
commission on a senti tout de suite
la tension des macronistes qui qui
refuse absolument cette commission
d'enquête on a envie de dire que si la
macronine avait vraiment rien à se
reprocher
elle accepterait cette proposition de
résolution sans problème donc le en fait
le simple fait de présenter cette
proposition de résolution au delà même
d'ailleurs de du fait de parvenir à
l'obtenir déjà le simple fait de la
présenter et de voir la réaction de la
macronie et déjà assez symptomatique
puis donc il y a ensuite ce texte pour
augmenter le SMIC à 1600 euros net soit
2050 euros brut mensuel la mise en place
de cette mesure serait financée vous le
préciser par le rétablissement de l'ISF
l'impôt sur la fortune alors c'était le
SMIC à 1600 euros c'était l'une des
propositions phares de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lors de la campagne
présidentielle elle a tout de même peu
de chances d'aboutir cette proposition
de loi alors oui alors hier je précise
que en fait la présidentielle on avait
proposé le SMIC à 1500 mais là on le les
années 1600 du fait de l'inflation c'est
à dire qu'on adapte effectivement
l'augmentation du SMIC à la à la
situation
alors peu de chance d'aboutir
effectivement dans la mesure où on en a
déjà parlé plusieurs fois dans
l'hémicycle à chaque fois on nous a
refusé cette augmentation
la macronie comme l'extrême droite
d'ailleurs défendue uniquement un
système de prime
qui ne permet pas de finalement de de
pérenniser réellement des augmentations
ça veut dire que les primes ça va ça
vient mais les augmentations de salaire
elles pour le coup elle elle reste et
nous on veut pour que les gens soient se
sentent en sécurité
sécurité financière et
donc
ce qui m'a frappé durant le passage en
commission
c'est que effectivement il y a eu tout
une tentative de sabotage de notre
projet de loi avec la droite qui n'a pas
arrêté de déposer des amendements pour
comment dire proposer des exceptions ça
veut dire qu'à chaque fois c'était le
SMIC à 1600 euros sauf sauf sauf et
notamment beaucoup on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils ont contre les gens de la
restauration mais il y avait pas mal de
propositions d'amendement à l'encontre
des personnes qui travaillent dans la
restauration puis donc il y a ensuite ce
troisième texte une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui veut inscrire le
droit à l'IVG l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse dans la Constitution alors
cette loi veut aller plus loin que celle
présentée par la majorité explique-nous
c'est quoi la différence entre les deux
lois
que ce droit soit constitutionnalisé on
veut aussi que le que le comment dire le
l'État s'engage à faciliter l'accès à
l'IVG
voilà comment dire parce que si on fait
juste constitutionnaliser le droit après
imaginons que je sais pas que l'il est
joué soit
un prix exorbitant non remboursé
uniquement dans des cliniques privées
enfin à ce moment-là
ça va bloqué son accès à de nombreuses
femmes donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est
s'assurer que toutes les femmes puissent
y avoir accès quel que soit leur revenu
vous avez ensuite plus loin dans la
liste votre texte le il est dans classé
6e sur donc la création d'une allocation
autonomie des jeunes oui oui donc en
fait
nous ce enfin
ce qu'on veut c'est permettre vraiment
aux jeunes d'avoir un comment dire de
pouvoir
faire leurs études sereinement sans
avoir à travailler à côté et c'est un
investissement à la fois pour leur
avenir mais si pour l'avenir de la
France parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
jeunes qui soient formés notamment sur
les questions notamment pour répondre à
la à la crise écologique
et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il nous semble
important de de proposer cette
allocation d'autonomie qui serait donc
2100 euros c'est à dire en fait le seuil
de pauvreté voilà et à l'occasion voilà
qui est enfin de façon générale en fait
on ne veut pas que on ne veut qu'aucune
allocation ne soit en dessous du seuil
de de pauvreté donc c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs même pour les le minimum de
retraite
on veut que ce soit aussi 1100 euros il
est maintenant l'heure de passer pour
finir cette émission à l'actualité
régionale l'hebdopolitique
[Musique]
toujours avec
Ersilia soudais député LFI de la 7e
circonscription de Seine-et-Marne une
circonscription qui comme beaucoup en
grande couronne connaît des problèmes de
transport votre circonscription et des
services donc par le RER B quelles sont
les retours que vous avez des usagers
depuis le début de l'année alors c'est
effectivement assez catastrophique le
RER B et je suis bien placé pour le
savoir parce que je l'utilise
le souci c'est que Madame Pécresse
dit régulièrement qu'elle veut rénover
le RER B dans les faits le fait
strictement rien
toutes les investissements sont mis sur
le Charles de Gaulle Express qui pour
vocation d'être en train des riches en
faisant gagner 10 minutes aux gens pour
aller à jusqu'à l'aéroport
sans s'arrêter par chez nous
et donc enfin finalement enfin ces
travaux de Charles de Gaulle exprès
d'ailleurs on impacté la ligne B de
façon négative
donc déjà
on a depuis un bon moment enfin les
trains ne circulent plus à partir d'une
certaine heure donc à 22h40 il y a plus
rien si voilà si vous travaillez tard
bon courage si vous avez envie de passer
un peu de temps à Paris le soir bon
courage aussi
après régulièrement et bon c'est vrai
qu'il y a comment dire assez
régulièrement j'ai aussi des retours de
de d'usagers qui n'en peuvent plus du
nombre de retard du nombre de trains
supprimés d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui
j'ai reçu un message sur Twitter
justement d'un usager enfin parce que il
y avait des soucis au niveau de la
branche de mitry-clay qui la branche en
fait de RERB qui passe sur ma
circonscription
donc j'ai entendu voilà que
effectivement enfin Madame Pécresse
parlait de l'augmentation
potenti pour avoir augmenté le prix du
du Pass Navigo pour commencer la crise
du covid je pourrai déjà qu'elle
s'occupe d'avoir des des transports qui
qui fonctionnent sachant que le RER B
c'est quand même un million de passagers
par jour et qu'avec les les Jeux
Olympiques 2024 s'il y a pas quelque
chose qui est fait rapidement on va vite
se retrouver dans une impasse parce que
le RER B a cette particularité de relier
l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle avec les
principaux sites des Jeux Olympiques
2024 donc je ne sais pas comment le RER
B va pouvoir fonctionner correctement à
ce moment-là quoi et je tiens à signaler
aussi que je pointe la responsabilité de
Madame Pécresse mais je tiens à signaler
aussi la responsabilité du Gouvernement
sur ce sujet le gouvernement aussi se
doit d'agir et je les ai la première
question écrite que j'ai faite au
gouvernement
lors de ma mandature c'est
justement sur la question du RER B et à
ce jour alors que je leur ai posé la
question en juillet je n'ai toujours pas
eu de réponse alors justement dans ce
contexte d'inflation des prix de
l'énergie on parle depuis quelques
semaines maintenant de plusieurs
scénarios pour l'augmentation du passe
Navigo alors premier premier hypothèse
pour que le passe reste à 75 euros
l'État devrait accepter donc d'éponger
la dette du précovide pour la
transformer en subvention ou bien
réduire la TVA sur les transports en la
passant de 10 à 5,5% et donc laisser la
plus-value à Île-de-France mobilité
deuxième scénario tout le monde encaisse
une augmentation de 7,5% on aurait donc
un pass Navigo qui passerait de 75 à
80,8 euros et enfin si l'État ne concède
aucun geste Valérie Pécresse explique
qui défait sur un contrat donc
d'augmenter le prix du passage à 100
euros aujourd'hui quel scénario vous
privilégiez vous
moi je pense qu'il ne faut pas
d'augmentation pour
l'état de enfin de s'assurer que enfin
c'est à l'état de comment dire de
prendre de prendre ça en charge cela
étant enfin ce que je vois derrière la
manœuvre de Valérie Pécresse c'est que
elle veut se dédouaner enfin de du fait
que de fin de l'augmentation du passé ça
veut dire qu'en gros moi je suis pas
pour que ça augmente pour les usagers
mais c'est à l'état de prendre fin de de
prendre ses responsabilités et bon elle
oublie c'est bah c'est propre
responsabilités à elle
cela étant l'augmentation du pas serait
dramatique dans la mesure où vont déjà
ce serait scandaleux dans la parce que
comme je l'ai dit il est les conditions
de transport sont déjà sont plutôt
mauvaises alors si en plus de ça on
augmente le prix les
usagers sont doublement perdants mais en
plus les les comment dire l'inflation
est-elle que les gens de plus en plus de
mal à vivre si en plus on leur on leur
augmente le coût du Pass qui permet à
beaucoup de personnes de pouvoir aller
travailler
je ne sais pas comment les gens vont
s'en sortir donc je pense que on n'est
pas non plus un pays pauvre on est je
veux dire même si même si effectivement
il y a il y a une crise énergétique en
ce moment voilà qui qui impacte nos
finances on n'est pas un pays pauvre
donc à un moment donné il faut savoir
juste savoir où chercher l'argent et
l'investir correctement enfin voilà
c'est que parfois quand ils veulent
enfin quand
je vois quand je vois parfois certaines
discussions budgétaires à l'Assemblée je
me rends compte qu'en fait il y a de
l'argent mais simplement on s'interroge
des fois sur les choix qui les choix qui
sont fait quoi merci beaucoup merci la
soudée d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle donc que vous êtes député la
France insoumise de scène et Marne nous
on se retrouve dimanche prochain à 19h
pour un nouveau numéro très bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]